pubmed contains more than 30 million
citations to articles in the biomedical
literature with new material added daily
it also includes citations to a small
but useful selection of online books and
documents
with a foundation in clinical medicine
pubmed includes citations to literature
on a wide range of biomedical and health
topics
including environmental health
social sciences
microbiology
genetics
and chemical and physical sciences
the largest component of pubmed is
medline the national library of
medicine's premier bibliographic
database containing citations and author
abstracts from more than 5 000
biomedical journals published around the
world
there is a process to determine whether
or not to include a journal in medline
in making this decision nlm considers
the recommendations of a group of
advisors known as the literature
selection technical review committee
the committee meets three times a year
to evaluate journals that have applied
to medline
journals are selected based on scope and
coverage editorial policies and
processes
scientific reader production and
administration and impact
pubmed also includes citations and
abstracts from articles included in
pubmed central or pmc
a free online full-text archive of
biomedical and life sciences journals
also hosted by the national library of
medicine
to be included in pubmed central a
journal must meet the quality criteria
of the national library of medicine
collections and meet the scientific
editorial and technical criteria for pmc
when research is funded by the national
institutes of health or nih
the results must be available to the
public
therefore individual articles reporting
the results of nih-funded research are
also included in pubmed central
pubmed central also serves as a
repository for articles reporting on
research funded by other public agencies
and private research funders that share
a similar mission to nih
records for these articles in pubmed
central that share research results with
the public are added to pubmen
even if the article is not published in
a journal selected for medline or pubmed
central
pubmed also provides access to the
national center for biotechnology
information's online bookshelf
bookshelf is comprised of more than 7
000 technical reports systematic reviews
clinical guidelines reference works and
other monographs
most pubmed records represent one
journal article
and are composed of fields that provide
specific information about the article
including the
journal source information title of the
journal article
names of the authors and their
affiliations
abstract published with the article
and publication type or description of
the type of article like review or
letter
for articles not in english the pubmed
records will also include the language
in which the article was published
when available the pubmed record will
provide research funding information and
associated study data
the national library of medicine adds
medical subject headings or mesh terms
to records from medline selected
journals
mesh terms provide quick access to the
topics of the article
most pubmed records are supplied
electronically by publishers and
enhanced with mesh and with links to
related resources by the national
library of medicine
in addition to providing free access to
pubmed via the web the national library
of medicine provides access to pubmed
data to researchers commercial vendors
and the public for repurpose and reuse
pubmed makes finding biomedical journal
information easy from anywhere you can
access the internet